den christoph metzelder wurde nun
anklage erhoben wegen des verdachts auf
verschaffung und besitz von
kinderpornografie
die ersten reaktionen haben natürlich
nicht lange auf sich warten lassen
oliver pocher hatte bereits im august
diesen jahres auf instagram heftig über
christoph metzelder gesprochen sehr
deutliche vorwürfe dort hervorgebracht
natürlich gab es direkt post vom anwalt
das will der bald fünffache papa aber
nicht auf sich sitzen lassen und
donnernd jetzt noch einmal richtig los
schämen sie sich und du bleibst
widerlich nur zwei von unzähligen pocher
zitaten der comedian wettert in seiner
neuen installer story mit voller wut
gegen christoph metzelder wegen seiner
früheren aussagen mit zelda sei ein
krankes schwein und solle geächtet
werden wurde pocher vom anwalt mit
zellers verklagt prompt bekommt auch der
anwalt im vom pocher untertitelten
anwaltsschreiben sein fett weg
pochers haltung ist klar er möchte sich
nicht den mund verbieten lassen vor
allem nicht von jemandem der zitat
pocher kinderpornografische fotos
verschickt habe mehr nachrichten und
breaking news nur bei bild schaut euch
hier das nächste video an und vergiss
nicht zu abonnieren